this video was made possible by
curiositystream
European country and like to think of
yourself as a well-traveled pretentious
intellectual you'll definitely take some
time to admire the buildings around you
you'll point to one and say hmm yes
that's a cathedral history and that's
one of the special things about the
place it looks old but if you look
closer Europe looks another way as well
everything is Stone
Cathedral is the most popular
attractions are made with local
materials and robust buildings Rock
they're they're made of Rock
in Venice Cathedrals are white and
that's because the white-colored istrian
stone in Paris the notadamus cream and
that's because of the cream-colored
Parisian lutition limestone and if you
go up north churches become brick not
easily accessible Limestone gave rise to
an artificial alternative the North had
plenty of clay and little quarries
but stone and brick are not the only
materials churches can be built out of
there's also wood
[Music]
in Norway you can find 28 staved
churches some of the most unique
buildings on the European continent that
look out of this world
Norway is home to the oldest and last of
their kind wood churches that have
lasted centuries
that's no small feat because wood has a
reputation for decaying and there's a
reason these churches look weird that
they're as strong as they are and you
can only find them in Norway
phenoscandia is a place of Timber while
Continental Europe is a place of masonry
and that makes sense wood is a great
insulator you need more Stone if you
want to insulate the same as wood an up
north insulation matters especially and
that's okay because luckily there's
plenty of wood to go around
compared to the Continental northern
Europe is pretty damn forested and
that's because agriculture doesn't help
trees and complex Landscapes don't help
Agriculture and Norway is very complex
it has a massive Coastline with the West
fragmented by mountains and cut into
complex networks of fjords and rivers
it's a landscape that can help make
experienced wood boat makers but it
makes wide-scale deforestation difficult
it also hinders communication which help
reduce the spread of Christianity that
came to Norway later than most and when
Christianity did come it wouldn't come
normally
between 1 100 and 1 300 when Stone
churches were in Vogue and built in mass
in Norway thousands of wooden staved
churches would be built instead
if we bring our attention to Sweden we
can begin to understand why in Calmar
Sweden staved churches would turn from
Timber into stone but there was a
pattern materials clustered Stone
churches belong next to each other and
on the coast and wood churches were
remote high density areas gave access to
more and better labor easier accessible
Stone and also came with easier land to
build upon
but in remote locations Craftsmen were
masters of wood no not Stone and wood
was more accessible and cheaper than
building with rock
it's why you'll find the Norwegian stave
churches of today and some of the
farthest remote places and obscure
fjords and high valleys The Limited
Norwegian Stone architecture that did
occur occurred in places with density
but Stone was more than evidence for
accessible materials a certain amount of
density or a good location it's also
evidence of a status hungry Rich Elite
see Big Stone churches and castles are
in some ways the historic big dick
measuring contest of the Medieval ages
and Norway is weird because historically
it had fewer and poorer landowners
compared to other parts of Western and
Northern Europe
and that's because topography and
geography can do more than lead to Wood
houses the argument goes Norway sucks
for cultivation only around three
percent is arable that's not a lot and
it's much worse than Denmark and
Southern Sweden who have wide fertile
valleys and large continuous planes with
Moraine soil the reason this matters is
because large planes with good soil can
lead to agricultural yields that provide
easier Surplus for Elites who now have
an easier time Gathering the Manpower
and then resources to produce Big Stone
buildings but if you have rugged
segmented land that doesn't produce easy
centralization and you don't have arable
land that provides easy Surplus
resources you're gonna have a poor Elite
that won't be able to easily build with
stone add on the fact that Norway is
made of largely harder metamorphic rock
while Continental Europe has easier
access to Limestone and Sandstone the
ultimate soft Stone building materials
and you create a recipe for a stone
disaster Norway doesn't have many Stone
buildings what so however and of the
ones that are built they're smaller in
size and made of super weird materials
like soapstone
soapstone is a crazy Stone literally
nobody builds with soapstone except for
Norwegians it's weird
of the ones that stand today we can
generalize them as three ranging from
simple to increasingly complex
what unites them all is The Stave staff
a vertical piece of wood
Church Builders would begin by selecting
especially tall trees either Scotch pine
or Norwegian Spruce and especially
strong and straight wood
and they would trim those trees removing
their tops bark and branches and then
leave them for years before cutting them
down giving ample time for the sap of
the tree to drain into its roots
this would solve multiple problems
the trunks would have less chance for
splitting and they'd be lighter which
made them easier to move and now the
roots with higher concentrations of sap
could be placed on top of fire in order
to extract very valuable black tar which
would come in handy later see the
churches were to be built on specific
natural landmarks where they'd be
especially at risk of facing elements
like wind rain and snow so the church
Builders had to do whatever they could
to make the buildings as robust as
possible
and luckily the builders were far from
amateurs
they built the churches on rough local
Stone to protect the bottom of the
church from Rod and they built the
churches so they'd be able to withstand
vertical loads produced by snow while
also remaining stable enough facing
lateral forces that came from hard winds
after the church was finished Builders
would then apply the black tar that they
collected from the original Timber to
make the wood hydrophobic
this tar gave the churches their unique
black texture and it still needs to be
reapplied today however the recipe for
the most effective tar has been lost so
it's applied more often today than it
would have been in the past
no wood detail was ignored where the
trunk ended but the Roots Began could
also be saved to make the curved knee
braces the most frequently used brace in
the church what the builders knew then
is that the base of a tree had to be
especially tight and strong and so it
could be repurposed for additional
structural Integrity in the building
the staves although unclear exactly what
was done to them are made of much
Superior Lumber than what we have today
and we don't know how to make the same
staves
even the pins and connectors that held
the wood together were made out of
common juniper known for being
especially rot resistant the wood that
held the vertical staves between the
larger ones had subtle carved holes that
could be used as drains for water
but if we look even closer we see much
more than the Fingerprints of
experienced wood Craftsmen the walls of
the stave churches are not just
connected but they're connected with lap
joints similar to what the Vikings use
to connect the holes of their ships flip
the trusses at the top of the church
upside down and you get a similar design
to that of the foundation of a Viking
ship the borgun staved church one of the
oldest and largest has dragons at the
top of its roof a common symbol in Norse
paganism and oddly enough the dragons
are placed higher above the symbols for
Christianity
these churches remote that they were
made it also a bit easier for those that
built and use them to cling onto their
Norse past the staved churches aren't
just wood you see they're a beautiful
baby bastard of Christianity and Norse
paganism
and some of the staved churches you can
find remnants of a Central Mass going
within the church Nave odd when that's
not exactly desirable in a church and
even weirder given the fact that the
builders would know how to build
otherwise so some theorize it was an
intentional spiritual addition a
connection to the axis Mundi the world
tree and the Norse religion within the
churches you can find intricate wood
carvings and ornaments as well as wood
heads not too far from the documented
wood poles with faces that early
explorers saw Vikings give sacrifices to
even the pillars of wood themselves
within the church aren't too far from a
Grove of trees an incredibly important
symbol in Pagan religion and rituals
but it goes even deeper many churches
come with explicit portals often
featuring the last judgment the stave
churches also came with portals but not
of the same scene instead of Christ they
showed fantasy animals like massive
snakes and dragons fighting each other
Twisted in Vines it doesn't seem like
it's referencing Christian Judgment day
but instead Ragnarok doomsday for the
nors
so no the churches aren't really weird
they're just a product of evolved Apes
adapting to their local circumstances
and constructing things that reflect the
local environment and materials
and if you want to know more about
evolved Apes I highly recommend checking
out the most insane series I've seen on
evolved Apes in my lifetime becoming
human
it's creatively directed by one of the
best team of editors I know on this
planet who are the only ones that go as
far as they do to visually explain
monkey schools I mean this with no
exaggeration there are literally no
documentaries on this planet visualizing
and explaining human evolution like they
are
and you can only watch it by signing up
for the streamy award nominated
streaming service nebula which is
thousands of other unique titles that
you can binge afterwards and the best
way to get nebula is by signing up for
the Curiosity stream nebula bundle that
you can now get with a holiday discount
of 42 that is less than a dollar a month
and is as cheap as it ever gets that's
crazy The Becoming Human series is worth
11.59 on its own but you can now pay
that amount by following the link at
curiositystream.com get becoming human
and then you can get a year-long
subscription for both curiosity stream
and nebula which means access to
thousands of different shows while
supporting independent creators that are
just trying to make you the best content
by following the link you can get
yourself or a friend a Christmas gift
while also giving a bunch of independent
video editors a gift as well
if you check out curiositystream.com you
will not be disappointed